are you ready yeah all right all right
ladies and gentlemen thank you for
listening to your favorite podcast you
know the name of it
you know what anyway ladies and
gentlemen I want to thank this gentleman
for coming to the podcast one of my
favorite sports sports debaters on the
on probably the arguably the best show
in sports on television on Fox orally
well you know I mean PTSD long you you
know what you right there with them but
mister Jason Whitlock so thank you for
coming to the - - thank you for having
me I think your Griffin yes we were just
talking at a podcast game is like um you
know next thing it's it's it's a way to
support yourself independently I have so
much respect for the people to do it and
the payoff if you have the
stick-to-itiveness yeah can be amazing
yeah I know yeah I'm trying yeah I'm not
there yet I don't got like you know two
people helping me out and all this stuff
it's just me but I know exactly what
you're saying I mean I've seen like
people grow you know like I did Joe
Rogan's podcast I'll you know who that
is
yeah Joe like he he has a building you
know with like Adam Carolla I mean I did
Corollas to here he's got a huge set up
yeah I saw a guy Dave Rubin who's more
into the political realm but he went
from something to now when you go to his
studio it's incredible it looks like a
television studio and when you watch it
on the air it's like this has got to be
shot at a major network but it's it's
people that have that spirit of
industriousness and just like I'm gonna
do for myself and if they stick with it
long enough and do a good enough job it
can really grow into something special
yeah sure can't like you like for
instance like your show your shows
speak for yourself is on Fox Sports
comes on every day at noon pacific time
i watch it every day i tape it every day
because I just I tape all I'd say
there's only two I take three shows if
I'm being honest I tell I tape I tape
first take which I don't watch all the
time because it's so long as two hours
yep and then sometimes it's like I don't
they just keep going on stuff that I'm
like okay I don't want to hear about
this and then PTI it's only thirty
minutes so you know I want that one and
then your those are my three in the
rotation but the ones i religiously
watch a PTI in your show I appreciate
that that we have more to offer over to
fs1 I hope you you know expand your
horizon and take a look at some of the
other things we have to offer but I
certainly appreciate the support of our
show I remember seeing you you used to
be on the ESPN and yeah and I started
tweeting at you back in the day when you
were on it when you were like a guest
host on PTI yeah I was actually people
too I was the first guest host ever on
PT oh really yeah back when they first
started out they said I was started
taking vacations yes I was the first
guest host and Tony and Mike took very
good care of me early in my career
Erick ride home that produces that show
too very good care of me early in my
career I they launched you know well I
can't let me take that back I was on the
sports reporters first one Sundays but
in terms of this daily television sports
debate thing Tony Kornheiser and Mike
will bots are the guys that put me down
yeah they they they liked other correct
their gold standard yeah right mm-hmm
but like so you've been a sports writer
because you spend you've been a
journalist I mean what's a sports bar
you've been a journalist for like how
long now I graduated Ball State in 1990
May of 1990 got my first job as a sports
writer I think in September of 1990 and
have been doing that ever since my first
job Eric I'd love to tell
five dollars an hour oh wow as a
part-time sports writer at the
Bloomington Harold times and so I
definitely through the sports riding
game work my way up the totem pole you
sure did
now my oh my up thoughts about sports
journalism is that I feel like it's like
if you go to a restaurant and you ask
the waiter how's the pie and there's
supposed to be like I wouldn't get to
apple pie today but they shouldn't trash
the whole restaurant so I kind of feel
like in sports journalism like you know
when when they're trying to tear down
you know an athlete tear down the sport
I kind of feel like hey you need this
sport to be thriving so how do you
balance that well I certainly if you
watch my show I'm very protective of the
NFL they sure are football was my
pathway out of poverty out of the out of
the hood you know no one was coming to
look for me as an 18 year old kid other
than football coaches I wasn't the
greatest student
and so I'm very protective of football
the individuals within football I didn't
care less about and I don't want to say
that like I have it in for those guys or
whatever because they do the players
actually make up the game but you know
I'm most interested in protecting the
game the players will come and go in
that and again you got to remember here
I'm a critic yeah yeah that's that's my
job
I'm a critic I review things that's what
you know when I got a columnist job in
1994 in Kansas City my job was to be a
sports columnist and basically a sports
critic and so you know when you're a
critic he criticized ride right yeah so
you know when I was in Kansas City I got
Carl Peters to the general manager of
the Chiefs he probably thought I was the
devil because I found ways to criticize
him
and the mistakes he made and you know
Marty Schottenheimer at times but look
I'm not opposed to and do celebrate even
the people I criticize Carl Peterson
when things went well I was a big
champion when they went poorly I was a
critic but but you you know we were
talking off the air and I guess we'll
get there now you you asked my
philosophy as a journalist and as a
broadcaster now where does it come from
and it mostly just comes from I said as
a kid when I cause I became a sports fan
one from playing but also I was a huge
Indiana pacer fan and the Pacers when I
was a kid were horrible they just joined
the NBA they were one of the worst
franchises in all the sports they once
had a telephone to save the franchise
woman they were asking and so I would
read the Annapolis newspapers there were
two of them at that time the star and
the inning that was news in the
afternoon and they covered the team as
if they were the Boston Celtics and
contending for champions every
Championships every year and it drove me
crazy as a sports fan I was like wow
what are you doing I want the people
ruining my team held accountable gosh
they're doing dumb things that are
ruining my team and no one in the media
will question them and as a kid I said
to myself I was like oh man they worried
about the coaches and the executives and
the players more than me the fan and the
reader of the newspaper and so when I
switched my major to journalism at Ball
State one of the main things I said was
I'm never going to forget the fan and
the reader and it was simple math for me
I was like I'd look at all this this
can't be a nap a star has a half million
subscribers mm-hmm the Indiana Pacers
have 12 or 13 guys on their team they
have two or three coaches handful of
executives at that time I was like
there's like 20 of them and there's a
half
million readers who am I gonna try to
please write that half million from
buddies 20 people over here and I just
thought simple math I'm gonna go for the
half million I'm gonna keep it real with
them try to entertain them try to tell
them what I really think and I won't
worry about those 20 people and you know
so now they've got MBA teams have eight
assistant coaches and ten players so
there's like 35 people you got to worry
about but you still don't care yeah I'm
35 they getting paid well you know it's
not my job to please them it's my job to
try to please and entertain a mass
audience I agree and I think you're
doing a good job that you're a truth
teller for sure you know and you vote
you are you know I I watch the show
enough to like get the nuances of the
things that you're doing which i think
is what people miss when they try to
criticize they just want to criticize
you for being like you know why you so
hard on this person or that person but
the other day on this show when you were
talking about the NFL in like sticking
up for the NFL when Antonio Brown was
saying that the NFL's racist and like
you really have a passionate opinion
about this generational wealth that
these black players are getting from the
NFL and for them to just trash it so
willy-nilly you you bring something to
you it's crazy because many of us that
were delivered from poverty through
football many of us probably weren't
gonna be doctors and lawyers right and
many of us if not for football taking us
to a college campus and opening our eyes
to all the possibilities the world has
to offer you know we might still be
right in our same neighborhoods doing
nothing or next to nothing I would
probably be running my dad's bar if not
for and again that's I love Master P's
lounge bar one of my favorite places on
earth but I'd probably be running that
bar and making 70 $80,000 a year as
opposed to what I'm doing now because of
football and I just think these guys
need to be very careful and if they
really understood we have this affinity
hip-hop that is a bit misplaced and
again I like hip-hop music I listen to
it but it does denigrate us it does
denigrate black women it does portray us
as balloons and but we're so loyal to it
because a handful of guys have made
millions of dollars in the hip-hop
industry
well damn near every NFL team creates
more black millionaires a year than
anything that's going on in the hip-hop
video yeah and I mean just one team I
think one team in the last 10 years has
probably made more millionaires than
them all of hip-hop
I wouldn't go the history but what up if
you see it you talk about there's
there's 52 players man maybe you twenty
of them are become millionaires you talk
about every single year every three
years you know I'm second in the history
of say the Raiders you know right how
many black players have become
millionaires in the Raiders and compared
to like what question about you know no
and and so I what I just want to ask
these players like you do realize for
black men and particularly and
particularly for masculine heterosexual
Christian black men I don't know if
there's an industry better than football
in terms of providing us an opportunity
to make life-changing wealth and I think
we need to be protective of that it has
done more for us far more than hip-hop
and I say the same thing about the
basketball but the numbers impacted by
football are so great that I think we're
foolish with our attack on football and
NFL ownership and by and so again I ask
people a lot of times what are you
really Pro black or you Pro liberal
politics because there's a major because
it's like if you Pro black like wow the
NFL Wow yeah doing some things I get it
and if you're Pro liberal maybe you have
problems with the values instilled and
football and things like that but if
you're just like hey I'm I'm Pro black
find me the industry that's better than
football yeah or and then in all of the
professional sports that go down with
that I was um I'm also interested like
when you you like you very hard on
LeBron James you know but but again I
know what you're a critic he's the top
of the mountain he could take the
criticism but is it does it have
anything to do with how you came up why
you seem to be like sometimes I feel
like you extra hard on the bronc
well it's when LeBron was getting can we
cuss on here oh yeah oh yeah [ __ ] it on
do you when he was getting [ __ ] on
when he left Cleveland with the decision
yeah I was one of the few people that
defended LeBron James and defended
maverick Carter when people were calling
him a clown in the aftermath of the
decision and so for me if you stick with
me long enough I'll go from a
flip-flopper critic to defender to
critic it just depends on the situation
there's a handful of people that I'm not
honest about in sports and generally
speaking it's it's people like Jeff
George who I grew up with are you
talking about Jeff George so I don't
give my full unadulterated opinion on
Jeff George because actually knowing
Noah's family there's a real affinity in
connection between Jeff George and I and
so I let people know okay when Brady
Hoke was the coach at Michigan Brady
Hoke played football at Ball State where
I played I was helped him when he was
the head coach at Ball State sir and I
let hey guys don't come to me for the
truth on Brady Hoke when he's the head
coach of the Michigan I'm gonna let you
know that he played at Ball State I have
a by everybody else pretty much I mean
cuz Magic Johnson's my favorite player
favorite athlete of all time and you've
been hard on him in the last like six
months so I think we're LeBron and I
have gotten crossways to be quite honest
with you is that if you my point of view
about
Forte's about male masculinity I'm just
not into victimhood at all mmm if you're
a healthy grown man I don't believe
you're capable really of being a victim
now let me walk that back cuz urk
everybody's capable being victimized
everybody could be victimized everybody
there's you don't got to act like a
victim yes and but I just think if
you're a healthy grown man don't don't
don't come to me looking to show me your
victimhood
I just wasn't raised that way my father
is the blackest person I ever knew and
he passed away three four years ago but
his whole existence was black and I love
to hear all these people on Twitter and
all these super elite wealthy black
people and they think so I mean my
father experiencing things in America
yeah that were really disturbing and
upsetting his solution always was all
Jimmy Whitlock's gonna correct this he's
going to build him a business in the
black community he built a brand new
home in the black community his
existence was black and he found
happiness right here in America he
wasn't running around ass off so for me
I can't believe my boss see Chrysler
told me not to read the autobiography
Malcolm X and that's what happened on
his deeds a factory worker at Chrysler
his boss says hey man we not about for
Malcolm X and so my father's reaction
was in life oh that's terrible ugh I
can't believe he did his okay i'ma leave
here build my own business and a damn
it's all gonna tell me what I can and
cannot read so he went into business for
himself
that's just my mentality yeah it's her
all this victimhood that I hear from
black men or what it's it's slow too
feminine for me and and it's just it's
self-defeating I don't think it's the
way to advance because take my the show
I do on
Fox Sports 1 most people most the
stereotypical walk black people on
Twitter or who are the bots or whatever
they've trained to say the stuff they
say over Twitter would be like man you
could never have a black show on Fox
Sports Rupert Murdoch he's racist yeah
oh we're not got a black show Holmes Fox
Sports Daniel is here Marcellus it's
dark Neos Uncle Jimmy and Tim look hot
in black Ashley oh they still racist
people and so you'd be surprised what
you can do if you set your mind to it
and don't make a bunch of excuses and
just put your head down and be a rock
solid dependable person you'd be
surprised who will invest in you and
support your vision if you conduct
yourself properly I think you're doing a
great job at that I mean I do like to
like I said I like to show a lot and
then when Marcellus first came on the
show I felt like he was like I got a
debate like you know he was like I'm
debating you like whatever you would say
you'd be like you wrong he would come
with it but the groove that you guys are
in right now is just like it's such
great television to watch and I love
most of the guys that you have on the
show like TJ Huisman uh he is he is
fantastic I'm talking about this with
Frank Caliendo we both talked about your
show a lot so like he's great tony
gonzalez is great even steven jackson
who gets on my nerves sometimes Steven
Steven it's like he is right where he's
you know he's honest about what he feels
about things you know and all the
athletes even though sometimes I feel
like these athletes don't understand a
position they do and they've been so
entitled for so long that they had these
weird opinions because like for instance
with LeBron James for instance like I
think when we finish and we look at
LeBrons career and the totality of his
career when we've give us three years
away from his retirement we don't look
back and be like this could have been
better
no question about it and that's part of
what I'm pointing out and
to analyze again I'm not into tearing
down LeBron I am into analyzing LeBron
which Adam times has translated it to
tearing him down it's really not it's
really just like I'm trying to LeBron
James has been a child star basically
yeah his whole ever since about age 14
and if you look at what happens to child
stars they're out here and a lot of them
have a hard time holding on to their
sanity yeah being famous and being
famous as a child and being catered to
as a child does some things to you and
that's what I think we're dealing with
with LeBron James everybody has this
mentality as it relates to LeBron oh my
god he grew up for I was like yeah for
about 10 11 years yeah and then once
they discovered like oh my god this
guy's a generational Talent there was a
bunch of grown men and women had rushed
into Akron to make sure we gotta get
this dude to age 18 and into the NBA cuz
there's a big pot of gold
and so LeBron James has been catered to
much longer twice as long as he lived in
poverty mmm so and so when you've been
catered to it changes you in many many
ways that are not good and he's done a
good job but he hasn't been perfect and
I think the Lakers are dealing with a
guy that's 34 35 years old has spent the
last 23 24 years being catered to and
it's difficult for them to deal with and
I think if you look around at the way
the other NBA players are reacting to
LeBron right now a lot of them see it
understand it's like now I'm good I'm
gonna do my own thing yeah well I think
also it's because like he's at the tail
end yeah like you know so now now people
are starting to like now they're gonna
start pointing out like cuz you know
you're in it as a professional athlete
you're only as good as your talent lets
you be you know you so people only go
and deal with your nonsense if you're
still got a 55 inch vertical and you can
hit three-pointers cuz once that starts
to wane people are kind of like yo man
you kind of got an attitude
there's no question and I listen the
point you made about looking in
retrospect when I oh man did he did he
get everything out of this is this so
it's the same question people ask about
Wilt Chamberlain when it was over you
know what and sometimes when you're born
with so much talent it's too much I
totally agree with you it talent without
having like you know self-awareness
right but no too much talent can stop
you from having self right exactly
because I even feel this way even people
that have been successful like when I
looking at Kobe Bryant you know I'm a
I'm a I'm a hope Kobe Bryant hater
oh I am but I'll but I love his game you
know I'm like I love to hate Kobe Bryant
that's how I've been my whole that's why
my Clippers fan but like even with Kobe
I feel like if he would have done two
years of college a year of college and
and and if he would have been able to
learn how to be a teammate with other
people is cuz he was catered to his
whole life too yeah you know he was a
rich kid and you know I could speak five
languages I know better I think that
it's not that he still wouldn't end up
with shagged cuz it would probably would
have been different but I think he would
have been a different player so even
someone like that who had a phenomenal
career I still think that he made some
missteps no question that he would have
been greater than he was you make it a
point I've never thought about had Kobe
spent two years in college he would have
surpassed Michael George oh I thought
that's the argument you make yes and
people don't understand the reason why I
go back to Michael Jordan either
legitimately or created the myth in his
mind that he got cut as a sophomore
right right and he created enemies yeah
but but not just that it speaks to the
firmer Michael Jordan was the third pick
in the draft and so what that says like
oh they thought there were some guys
with more talent the taller guys because
a safer man yeah gay basketball is a
game that caters to the taller guys and
so Michael Jordan had let in again it
sounds crazy to say but he didn't have
all the perfect
physical gifts that LeBron has yeah or
he wasn't such a over-the-top talent
like Wilt Chamberlain and LeBron were
and so he worked on some things remember
Jordan wasn't a great outside shooter
worked on that I just think sometimes a
really gifted person with a flaw or two
is better and if you look at Tom Brady
six round pick and what has driven him
and what has made him have
self-awareness I think it's his
shortcomings and-and-and I get your
point about Kobe Bryant is one I'm
telling you I'd never thought of there
but yet had Kobe spent a couple years in
college they're gonna change this
perspective I think yes he would have
been a better teammate he wouldn't have
done that thing to Shaq he would have
liked he you know see the thing is is
like now this is what I say about LeBron
James I think LeBron James is so good he
is so great that even at the when he is
not doing the things that say Jordan did
to make himself he's still better than
everybody yes and there's no he's like
well why it made me subconsciously it's
like I'm already look at me look what
I'm doing well I'll tell you the other
thing that that happened to LeBron James
and this is not trying to beat up on him
it's just trying to explain him is when
you grow up the way that he did no
relationship with his dad a mother that
was you know not perfectly ideal LeBron
had to rely on LeBron James at a very
early age yeah sure LeBron had to be the
man of his house at his own mommy and
daddy at a very early age and in LeBrons
mind I don't blame him for resi the
conclusion I'm the only person I can
count on yeah and so when I get on a
team and I look around as a coach that
wants to do this to do that or teammate
that wants to do the brahmic not trust
me I got this let's do it my way my way
brought me out of Akron with no dad and
and a mom that was you know not
perfectly ideal and it got me all the
way here and look I've won three
championships and I made all this money
how can my way be wrong right where
if I had the proper support been in some
other team environments he I think he
would be able to submit himself to the
will of others to me he would have
surpassed them all ya know he just put a
bit like to me I don't even mind even
right now as the state of where it is
right now if you want to argue that
LeBron James is the best player ever
I'll listen to that argument and I'll be
like okay maybe I agree or disagree but
it's a legit argument right that's how
great he is
and I'm saying like just this is man
this is why I get mad at like when I
some of the guys you have on the show
what Nate's because these professional
athletes when they start talking I think
to myself you know what
you guys aren't qualified to run a
thirteen billion dollar business because
when what's best what's best for LeBron
James and his family may not be what's
best for the entire league and so like
the and so now these this disdain age
league is going hey listen we paying you
35 million dollars you could live in
Cleveland you know you can live in
Milwaukee you can live in Minnesota you
can live in wherever the hell we put you
could this eight 1965 where you have to
take a bus you know you know you know
you can play seven back-to-back games
now man you live in like a king - you're
37 and then you can do whatever to want
what you want for the rest like but for
now I need you to like help the league
out more than you helping out your
family there's no question and it's a
struggle sometimes on the show where I
try to push the athletes to go maybe you
gotta take a step back and just not look
at everything from the athletes point of
view you know they sure do what about
the fans yeah what about the ownership
what about the just there's so many
other elements to sports and it's fine
too
let's examine the athletes perspective
but let's also try to look at things
from other people's perspective and
sometimes that's hard and look it's it's
it's easy for me because I was a
mediocre college athlete became a
journal
so the over I've now been a journalist
for much longer than I was an athlete
right and being a journalist is a better
journalist and a better journalist or
was that that's not an OP no really good
job but and so when you start looking at
things journalistically you have to look
at things much broader and you have to
oh here's what the athletes thing here
is what ownership thinks here's what the
coach thinks here's what fans think and
you got to factor that all in and you've
got to write stories and think about
things and talk about things from that
point of view and a lot of the athletes
just haven't had to do that and and so I
get where your frustration and struggles
from but again it's no great because I'm
gonna tell you what she what she said
about what's transpiring what the show
is like Marcellus is so smart
yeah and he's heard me push that angle a
lot of way hey man let's take a step
back and look at ever he's doing that
and it's elevating the conversation well
you know what's happening with Marcellus
is he is starting to have a longer
career as a television host journalist
himself a TV you know then he has a
football player I don't mean and then so
he's starting to like a geek I love
Marcel's he's you guys together it's
just great
I love the Whitlock's they come in hard
you know sometimes you go it's like real
hard and then you go
Marcellus what do you think and then I
love when he just goes I disagree and
then he says his point and then you guys
have a thing and I and that's great but
like I say though these athletes that
come on I don't think they this error of
the NBA right now we're gonna look back
on it and we're not gonna look back on
it fondly because what we've missed out
on is starting with you know we had go
we had Oklahoma City they're playing the
Golden State Warriors and there's this
epic battle a team comes back from 3-1
and you think wow they're gonna fight it
out in the Western Conference for years
to come
Kevin Durant makes the weakest decision
a superstar can ever possibly make it's
just a lot about is like yeah I get it
it's like why not you know I'm making
all 35 million dollars and I
why should I work hard you know me let
me go do this so he goes and does that
and now we don't get that rivalry you
know that rivalries now dead then we get
this epic Golden State Cleveland rivalry
and even though it wasn't a real rivalry
it's just a testament to how great
LeBron James is the only reason why we
even thought we'll maybe could he
possibly when we look back on are we
like there's no date they had no chance
of beating them once they got Kevin
Durant but we still thought maybe LeBron
can do it we had that now that's gone
right now that's that's out of here and
it just that's all that it is now and it
just no what what I will say though Erik
I hate it
I agree but what I will say Erik is I
think the current athletes have figured
it out oh this is just I blame I blame
ownership like they need to like scrap
the whole thing and start over no no no
but I'm talking about like the the
collective bargaining and I and I agree
with you that tell me but what I mean is
I think Kawhi Leonard in this decision
he just made is like no no screw LeBron
James I'm coming to your house and I'm
gonna fight you in your house I really
believe that no I I agree with you on
that but see that I think Kawhi Leonard
has a certain level of like pro like
competitiveness in him yeah but even
still listen he missed a free throw that
would have got him to Championships okay
the first he would have taken a
championship away from LeBron if he had
hit a free throw that game was over they
had their things set up okay
so even he he's on this load management
in Toronto and then he was like okay now
I'm gonna come it's like I don't like
even though I'm a clipper fan I don't
like his choice you don't like him
coming to the Clipper I love him coming
to the Clippers as a clipper fan as an
overall NBA fan I think why not stay in
the East and dominate the East the way
LeBron do for years to come because look
he made it clear he wanted to come home
to LA and but I think given their steps
to getting back to reality and steps to
getting back to the old competitive
spirit and I think why
I just took a major step towards that
and so if he comes to LA and makes the
Clippers a championship team given the
Clippers history it's gonna be one of
the most amazing stories in all of
sports
and if he does it while also undermining
the last two or three years of LeBrons
career it's an even more incredible
story and if that happens I think you'll
see other Domino's because what Kevin
Durant did was follow LeBrons blueprint
LeBron went down to Miami to chase
titles and so Kevin Durant took it to
the next step I'll go to the already
champion 73 win team being chased out if
Kauai has success here everybody's the
next generation the players are gonna
want to do it the kauai way and get that
respected Kauai is together I hear you
but it's not that difficult of a choice
like let's say it had nothing to do with
LeBron James okay if you look at the
Lakers and the Clippers and you're just
trying to decide between the two and
you're you realize that this whole like
you know myopic feeling about the Lakers
is is like it's it's not it's not
warranted after because in the last ten
years they have not been good right you
look at like as you go magic left he
comes in leaves the circus it's a circus
over there they got a coach that like
they got Jason Kidd sitting on the bench
you got just coached up Frank Vogel who
was one out of the league he can't even
get a job right you know you got all you
got the the guy that everybody hates
wasn't that the GM that all the other
places
polenka so if you're a quiet Leonard to
you so you got that or you got the dude
that's got fifty billion dollars a
championship coach a team that's like
ready-made they they took the the Golden
State Warriors with Kevin Durant to six
games you know you they got cap space
they got big incremental steps I know
but I'm nothing happens overnight
you know like with silver you pick
excuse me but I said which team would
you pick between the Lakers and Clippers
Clippers yeah I could by the way LeBron
should have picked the Clippers
probably if he but again LeBrons ego and
things like that at the time but I don't
have a problem I think Kauai has taken
the league a step in the right direction
I think this season of NBA play is going
to be amazing and interesting and I
think the following season when Kevin
Durant comes back it's gonna be even
more interesting and then I think that
I'm hopeful and prayerful that Zion
Williamson is gonna be 260 pounds this
year and I think he's gonna be a force
of nature and I think that Zion
williamson's is a guy that will play his
whole career in New Orleans and I think
he's really going to be the next super I
hope and pray the next superstar in the
NBA
i-i-i-i I hope that that happens too cuz
he's so just an explosive player but I
just I'm 50/50 on it because we've seen
that before
I mean he looks like Blake Griffin I
mean Blake Griffin without explosive in
cotton aw man he was that explosive
nothing we just forgetting like how he
was jumping okay you go to Blake why
wouldn't you go to Charles Barkley
because Charles but no charts block he
was way better than I am Williamson I
mean he just it's not even close
it's not it's not even close just in
terms of like his speed his like you
know just as just his power that Charles
Barkley played with I don't see Zion
Williams as Charles Barkley yet you know
and then Charles barley 19 but go ahead
I agree but then that's why I'm saying
it's like it's if he will see what he
does it says work ethic let's see what
he does in his rookie year and it's
gonna be hard in the West but I just
hope that but look brake foot Griffin's
a great player I love Blake Griffin you
know I mean he's gonna venture off to
call him no I think no I think Blake
Griffin is like he was just as explosive
he was like that kind of play he was
jumping over people and doing all that
stuff because if you take the Duncan off
Lake Griffin played college basketball
right yeah yeah two years right for two
years right yeah and you know Zion was
there for one and created a circus and
an excitement and an energy it was an
either that I understand that Blake
Griffin didn't remotely do at Oklahoma
but coming out I know
Oklahoma's different than Duke but go
ahead is dis is a lot different
and then they also didn't win you know
there's been a lot of great players at
Duke that have been great at Duke that
went on to win national championships
who are sucking a bag in the NBA right
now question you know we'll see but I'm
hopeful to see he seems like a good guy
he's got a great smile he's got a great
attitude we want him to be good and
that's the thing about when you look at
professional athletes we it's like when
they first come in we had this hopes and
we want them to live up to those
expectations problem is half of them
don't live up to the expectations you
know I know
girlfriend only see that Blake Griffin
knew he was talking about it so my list
my Blake Griffin like little real
bobblehead doll fell he knows we talking
about him okay
I mean like I say III enjoy the show and
all the athletes you have on the show
and I think I fit I feel like you get
into some of them because like I'm
watching the show I feel like they have
grown from the experience you know like
I said I mentioned again TJ Guzman John
is just like great I think he has grown
and the experience to like where he's
like you know he's I'm ready for his
opinion well here's what I think is
happening on the show and why we're in
such a good place is that social media
has had such a negative impact on the
mainstream media and what I and we have
tried to do would speak for yourself
is create an environment where you can
be really honest without paying a price
and and so how that happens is is it I'm
always gonna be the bad guy and so it
doesn't matter what you say on this show
I'm gonna take the heat for it and I'm
good with it
and so that liberate s-- everybody else
to be more honest I think if you look
across the board at a lot of
the media they're so concerned with
Twitter backlash that they compromised
what they say I'm so unconcerned same
thing in comedy man yes yeah I'm so
unconcerned with it and have tried to
create an atmosphere on the show and
just room for everybody to be themselves
and part of that is Uncle Jimmy plays a
role in that
his comedy pushes the envelope so far
then it creates room for us to crack
jokes yeah there's like well how can you
be mad at that joke with like crack
did you hear what Uncle Jimmy and so it
made a shield for you
yes I'm pushing boundaries and just
trying to get us back to reality because
again I'm like how could Dave Chappelle
be that celebrated during the Dave
Chappelle show and be always the
greatest comedians ever he he's the new
Richard Pryor and then we get five seven
eight years away from his show and it's
big you couldn't air his show right now
I know it's crazy like you I you do talk
about social media a lot and I'm with
you on this 100% I just and I think that
with all the things that have been going
on in society right now me too you know
the Kapernick nonsense and all that
stuff is like so now people are just
like ready you know they're ready but
that but I I'm a believer that the
Twitter universe that's not what people
really think not at all it's not even
like it's not even like middle America
could care less about what's going on on
Twitter it's just these like entitled
liberal [ __ ] that live like you know on
the coast on the coasts I'd see them
with their pretentious attitudes you
know the ones that are far left not the
good ones you know I mean like people
that are like more moderate to people
that like didn't know that nuance and
things it's these people on the either
side that actually are that these people
that like overly sensitive to angry and
then anything they see they want to turn
it into like you know it's you know
Nixon or something you know again I
don't know how y'all Watergate I don't
know how y'all working comedy now
because most of the [ __ ] that I think
funny you couldn't say right now I know
man this what they're doing there
they're at the comedy clubs now very
quite a few of them now are taking the
cell phones and locking them up you have
to put them in a thing to watch the show
you know it's just like can we can we
experience this cuz I got at a comedy
show I just want to be like can we just
have this moment and keep it here no
they want to like you know I had this I
had this experience where I was I was
out of the Kentucky or someplace like
that I think was Kentucky in like so I'm
ending the show I got the landing gear
out I'm about to like you know come in
for a landing like we did a good night
drunk girl in the front row starts
acting up she's just going at me for no
real I don't know why I take out my
phone and I start taping her you know
shouldn't have done that
because that made everybody else tape
now in the middle of the taping she
tries to hit the phone out of my hand
from the back it looks like she hit me I
get a week later I get an email from TMZ
Eric we run with this story about how
that heckler hit you you know and I'm
like what so it's like if so that's how
you know that so it couldn't just stay
we couldn't just had this moment it was
like people like we have to share this
with everyone and now it's out of
context yes it's out of context and when
it's out of context people put their own
context on it and then they reap it that
on the internet and now all of a sudden
it's like a wildfire that just burns but
it doesn't even burn for that long
because people forget and then they move
on to the next thing but what could
happen is some comedy club owner could
pick it up over social media and then
just say you know what it's better not
to have it I only want to deal with it
yeah I know he didn't do anything wrong
but I deal with the headache everybody's
making that week choice that oh my god
let's let's just put let's just cancel
that and not have to deal with the
controversy not have to think through
defend this it's not worth the headache
it's not worth the the little Twitter
lynch mob and I just I'm so prayer for
just let this go away man if these
executives would just wake up because
I've been saying do you mean wish
NATO came up yeah look that had to be
three four years ago now maybe longer
and I can't remember who was trending
all over Twitter sharknado structure and
then the ratings came out and no one
watched that's and I started tweeting it
I was like this is what I'm talking
about this Twitter is not reality ya
know and I don't I'm not even gonna put
a name on this but but I don't mean to
be offensive towards the person it's
somebody I watched and they'll know who
I'm talking about but there's some
people that I have three four five
million Twitter followers and then they
launched a television show and they
can't they struggle to get a hundred two
hundred thousand people to watch so they
don't have three or four million
followers right I don't know what they
have but they're not followers we'll see
what you can look at this is what I'm
this is what I do like if you look at
somebody's following let's say they have
a million followers they put up a tweet
and it has 3,000 likes that's they're
following that that's it cuz that's the
engagement mm-hmm so if you have a
million followers and like you're not
getting a million likes you know then
what is what does it really mean you
know what I mean that's what you really
have to look at you just have to look at
your engagement like who's listening
who's looking at it you know so they
have some of these analytics they'd like
to show like on Instagram they'll show
you like you know 23,000 people saw this
but you know only this many people liked
it so it's really about the engagement
so the more the merrier I mean social
media look it's a tool it's a tool but
it should not be used relative what in
my view it can be but you know but but
in the same way that like you know
anything can be destructive if you have
the wrong way you drink too much you
drink too much well yeah you could drown
on some water you know you know I mean
but so I know I know you have strong
opinions about Twitter and it's
especially with some of the things that
have gone on I got like I'm 100 with you
on the Kaepernick situation I even
talked about it on my last comedy
special about kneeling at work like you
at work okay you're at work if I owned a
Starbucks and one of my employees was
like you know
something some sort of protest and then
in its turning away my customers I would
be like hey you know the police station
it's down the street
go kneel there why don't you go over
there and kneel there like he easily
could have called a press conference and
be like I'm gonna be out in front of
City Hall and I want to talk about this
and then I would have been with him 100%
but how lazy is it did you gonna do it
at your job well just because you have a
TV audience because it was always about
his anger about the way the 49ers treat
him it was never about alleged police
brutality but but I hear a lot of people
that get upset that or the NFL should
allow that and they're denying him his
rights and this is proof they're racist
and it's really just poop they're
business people because take my father
again on the neighborhood tavern in
Indianapolis in the hood if he had an
employee that was doing something that
was irritating 3% of his customers just
3% he would put a stop to yeah
and so if what Kaepernick was doing was
irritating 2 to 3% of the NFL's customer
base they have every right to stop that
yeah and anybody and I listened to
people's reaction and I'm just like
they've never owned a business they and
north and north should they ever owned
you know the NFL's not publicly run you
know what I mean it's not like the post
office you know what I mean the DMV and
NFL's run by the government so then they
so we allowed to let you fall on it like
no this is like one of those we reserve
the right to serve who we want and and
we have our own rules amongst our
employees and I have no I just don't
have any problem with that but like
again people love jump into racism but I
love jump into like going back to the
beginning where you would talk about
this victimhood like you know finding it
they'd like to find how you know
can it be translated a different way if
it can let's find out what that is and
then maybe find a middle ground find out
where you may have been wrong well what
I concern myself most with it's like
it's poison for young people you know
I'm 52 years old and when you get this
age you start realizing like BAM life
goes by quick and so if you spend all of
your twenties looking for your
victimhood and looking for safe spaces
and looking for people that offend you
if you you're losing a lot of time that
you could be out doing things to empower
yourself to empower the people around
you to put yourself in a position where
any of these in Justices won't affect
you or your family if you're just
running around trying to scrub every
white person's feeling or opinion you
disagree with scrub that away
that's time you're not invested in
yourself and in the people that matter
most of you hopefully your friends and
family and so I I just think we fill in
our young people with a poison it's
gonna be self-destructive or
self-destructive and put them behind
their competitors because for the most
part young white people are not running
around trying to fix black people mm-hmm
we're running around trying to fix white
people that's counterproductive let them
fix themselves
you know it's err you and I both have
weight problems I'm gonna worry most
about mine I'm going to do try to do
something about drag me how dare you I'm
not worried about you you know what I
want to end on one other thing I wanted
to talk to you about is I know you get a
lot of like you get a lot of pushback
actually from black people sometimes
black people come at you like you know
as if like you know you like why you
talk
about black people who are you talking
about black people you know like I sold
on Twitter ones like oh it's uncle
ruckus they like to call you you know
they like you know it's like just cuz
you're like you know you you have a you
want to live to a higher standard and I
realize there's a lot about the
upbringing of your dad like the way your
dad said I don't care about artists
that's going on I'm gonna rise up so
then there's an attitude I feel like
there's an attitude from you that's like
we could all do that let's not make
excuses so then you come hard at well
it's see it's translated as like you're
being hard are you being like you know
the way they say but I what do you
what's your response to that well my
primary concern is black people because
I'm black that's my primary it's not
that I'm unconcerned about others but
that's my primary concern and so how did
the people that love me express their
concern for me when they saw me doing
things that they thought were wrong they
told me and I listen you have to listen
every night oh yeah I'm right there here
but my dad didn't go one out to white
neighborhoods and try to correct their
kids neither did my mother and so what
you're hearing is someone expressing the
kind of love that I received as a child
growing up for my both my parents my
grandmother my brother and sister and
you know we express love to each other
by hey that's a great job Jason that
that's good what you did on the football
field but could you get your grades up
and my father was constantly on my ass
about the way that I dressed and a bunch
of other things that he thought were
wrong that I was doing he stayed in my
ass about and it's not because he hated
me it's because he actually loved me and
wanted to see me do better than him that
was always the director from my parents
do better
we don't made a bunch of damn sacrifices
my mother was a factory worker my father
didn't graduate high school you got to
do better than
and so I think if you look at white
people who we like to compare ourselves
to white people have no problem
criticizing each other none whatsoever
go look at their behavior towards Donald
Trump they got no problem
criticizing white people we think
there's something if we don't criticize
each other and blah blah blah and if we
focus our energy on criticizing and
fixing white people that there's some
special power in that and our lives are
gonna somehow be better I just
completely disagree with that or if just
because it's black we have to be like
well this is great
yeah and then just the other I can't
stand that yeah by the perfect by just
the the job and the career I've chosen I
talk about football and basketball
pretty much every day on the show 70 to
75 percent of the athletes in those
leagues or black just by that I'm going
to be talking about black people but if
you watch the show I got no problem if I
think Jon Gruden is doing something
stupid yes Steve Kerr any white people
they can get it too and and they do but
because I'm talking about sports
dominated by black people it seems as if
yeah you only talk about black people i
watch the show religiously and yes you
are you get everybody gives it the same
including me because if you really watch
the show air have you seen how many
times i clown myself
no I'm out still mine I'm telling real
stories about myself a lot of time and
they're humorous and things but this
truth in them the other day I thought it
was great did Marcela's corrected you on
something and you just immediately went
like thank you know what thank you for
correcting me I'm wrong you're right yes
we'll be right back you know I mean yeah
I was like I thought I just I was at
home just like good for you because it's
just a rare thing that you see but again
just to close it out it's just like I I
appreciate the thing that you've created
on speak for yourself I have on the
shirt I stole when I was on the show
speak please
and you social um
shoutout to Darnell but uh I I
appreciate like the camaraderie that is
being built on the show because here's
something that I hate I don't want call
to dude out but I'm gonna say what it is
but it's a white comic friend of mine
you know you might know him but you know
this is one thing I don't appreciate it
sometimes by people they look at your
show and they might if they're white and
they might be like you know sometimes
they it's uh you know it's it gets a
little talk about black stuff a lot you
know and I just go damn you never say
that about us like if it's Sports Center
and like know if it's friends right all
they do is write relationship you know
hey no black man get a taste we're on
the same age isn't what I was coming up
I had to watch like late like I got like
I had oh I'll never forget his argument
I had with one of my white comic friends
way back in the day and he was just like
yeah I don't watch Martin you know is I
don't relate to it you know he said and
I was like you don't have to relate to
it
to find it funny like I mean yes oh my
god like I watch friends Seinfeld i
watch all these shows that are
predominantly white and I enjoy the [ __ ]
out of them I was on a show that was all
white and I'm mixed you know what I'm
saying I was the color on the show you
know I mean so it's like it's like it's
just weird that like so I'm gonna
encourage people out there that don't be
don't don't be afraid of the black faces
that you see on speak for yourself and
just like ignore that and just like hear
the things that they're talking about so
I just it's amazing that here's another
sports racism and and social prejudice
and all these kind of things that go on
Society you could see it in sports and
how long it takes for it to go away
so it's generational so it was all white
and am ba then it had a few black
players play that took a long time
now there's there was a lot of black
players and they started letting people
coach and so now there's a lot of black
coaches then they started letting blacks
black people be GM's and and then now
there's one black owner yeah like we're
a hundred years away
from where this is gonna be completely
gone but sports is a great way to look
at it sports is pure
it's an elitist system it's just all
about your performance to meritocracy so
a meritocracy yes
now and not a perfect one but it is a
meritocracy but but I will say this to
the sweet spot and again to use this
name in 2019 it's hard to do because
there's so much baggage with it but the
sweet spot we're trying to hit would
speak for yourself is the same sweet
spot The Cosby Show hit the same sweet
spot The Fresh Prince of bel-air here
right the same sweet spot that Oprah hit
is you can be a black show no question
about it and reach a mass audience right
and I think that whoever you heard that
from if they stick with the show they're
going to figure out the show is for
everybody yes it does primarily lean on
black host and talkers but the show is
for everybody and I think when you
really look at what's successful on
television from for black people
it is The Cosby Show it is The Fresh
Prince of bel-air it is what Oprah was
in her heyday and the book Empire you
know even Empire at certain time was the
most popular show on TV hey I don't know
if I would compare us there I'm not
denigrating Empire we're in two
different lanes
it was an all-black show to suppose
popular show on TV that's all I get
but but what I mostly what I see that
you being hard again on black people
what I'm saying is if you look at the
people on our show
Marcellus his wife and kids Darnell the
young kid we have on him and his fiancee
uncle Jimmy and his baby mamas just keep
it all his baby mama see him would be
huge we got a what we're just trying to
be as a reflection of how we really are
and I think when the Fresh Prince and
Cosby wrong people oh my god black
people are doctors they're lawyers like
Uncle Phil blah blah blah and we
probably said yeah yeah we are and I
think if you watch our show yours you'll
see every bit of black America on that
show and it's like yeah that's who we
are and I think eventually that that
authenticity will cut through and it
won't be offensive or won't put anyone
off so I just I love where I show is
right now and again I hope that joke
latter marks Larry the guy Ric Bucher to
come on white guys to come on our show
great white guys are yeah Marcus where's
one of my favorites I just the de
sensible dude yeah and so it's a show
for everybody as it is you know what
we're gonna close there I mean this has
been Jason Whitlock I appreciate you
coming on I want you to come on again in
the future and other things are going on
I guess a I think it shows great I want
you to continue it I think you are a
strong powerful voice in sports
journalism and just even journalism in
general I think you know that the show
is a testament to your journey that
you've gone through and now you now you
got in it is in a great sweet spot and I
hope that is growing and more people
watch it and you guys got to watch it on
Fox Sports
speak for yourself everyday 12 p.m.
Pacific time so make sure you check that
out and this has been the great Jason
Whitlock and I appreciate you coming on
brother thank you
y'all